y estamos listos
para darle armas a todos aquellos que se
declaran listos para proteger la tierra
del pueblo ucraniano
a todos aquellos que tengan experiencia
militar o de combate
[Música]
para que puedan ir al centros que hayan
sido organizados
planas ese gesto para que puedan ser
movilizados
esta mañana
hacemos un llamado a ustedes para que
también donen sangre
para poder salvar a los heridos
y ahora
hablaremos un poco más sobre cómo
defendernos
como nuestro futuro depende de la
del hecho de que tenemos que trabajar
juntos
porque tenemos todos los bienes
necesarios
ucrania
este es inductor o necesario puede
proteger los intereses del pueblo
ucraniano
muy bien
ella
hoy
tenemos a los ciudadanos de todos los
países para que digan que estamos
luchando por la libertad están listos
para defender
sus hogares y sus pueblos
esos ciudades quisiera decir decirles a
todos ustedes que
la decisión del consejo nacional de
seguridad
y apoya
a todos aquellos que estén listos para
movilizarse por nuestro país esta mañana
queridos ciudadanos
esta mañana es un momento histórico
sin embargo
la historia es diferente
para rusia y es diferente para ucrania
hemos tenido relaciones diplomáticas con
rusia
pero ucrania no se rendirá no entregara
su libertad sin importar lo que
cualquier persona de moscú pueda pensar
y esto es de supremo valor para nosotros
hemos sido atacados esta mañana por la
federación rusa
como
la alemania nazi atacó durante la
segunda guerra mundial
la luz está en el camino de la maldad
los ciudadanos rusos tendrán que tomar
una decisión el día de hoy
qué parte quieren tomar qué camino
quieren tomar y
este es el momento
para bajar a las calles y pedir el fin
de la guerra con ucrania
y me gustaría dirigirme los ucranianos
para nuestros ciudadanos que hablan ruso
sé que
esta información
no será transmitida
en los canales de televisión robots y
chivas
porque estará censurada en rusia
pero nadie puede censurar la historia
queridos ciudadanos
todos ustedes todos aquellos
que tienen miembros de sus familias
y también los periodistas algún llamado
a ustedes para que comunican para que
les cuenten la verdad de lo que está
ocurriendo
los mantendremos informados
con una actualización cada hora